Morgan began taking Pilates with her mom from this woman named Mary Archbold during her sophomore year of high school. And the way the class worked, I guess, was like most Pilates classes. Mary Archbold would demonstrate poses, and they would watch her carefully. And Mary Archbold would spend a lot of the class walking around, correcting students' positioning, pushing down their shoulders and adjusting their hip alignment, standing right next to them, touching them.
摩根在高中二年级时开始和她妈妈一起参加玛丽·阿奇博尔德女士的普拉提课程。我想这门课的运作方式和大多数普拉提课一样。玛丽·阿奇博尔德会演示动作，学生们则仔细观察。玛丽·阿奇博尔德会在课堂上走来走去，纠正学生的姿势，按压他们的肩膀，调整他们的髋部对齐，甚至直接站在他们身边触摸他们。
And I mention that only to say Morgan and everybody else in the class got a really good look at her close up for like an hour.
我提到这一点只是为了说明，摩根和班上其他所有人都曾近距离地观察过她整整一个小时。
I was in her classes for about probably two times a week for a year, almost a year, until I realized that she didn't have two full arms.
我参加她的课大约一年了，每周两次，直到我意识到她其实并没有两条完整的手臂。
That seems crazy.
这听起来太疯狂了。
Yeah.
是的。
To be fair, a lot of people were fooled. Mary Archbold is very good at concealing something you would think would be hard to conceal. Her right arm is a regular, full arm. And her left arm stops at the elbow. And she does wear a prosthetic arm, but it's solid and the joints and hands don't move at all. If you actually looked at it, you would see it's obviously fake.
平心而论，很多人都被骗了。玛丽·阿奇博尔德非常擅长隐藏一些你认为很难隐藏的东西。她的右臂是一条正常的完整手臂，而她的左臂在肘部处截断了。她确实戴着假肢，但那是实心的，关节和手部完全无法活动。如果你仔细观察，会发现它显然是假的。
But in addition to teaching classes, she performs professionally as a dancer, and has figured out ways to move so that the audience cannot tell. When she auditions, directors and choreographers can't tell, and the caster. And Morgan discovered the truth about Mary's arm only when Mary outed herself. She decided to do a show on stage about the experience of having just one arm. The show is called Jazz Hand . Get it? Jazz Hand -- the woman is a professional dancer-- Jazz Hand : Tales of a One-Armed Woman .
但除了教学，她还是一名专业舞者，她找到了一些动作技巧，让观众无法察觉。当她试镜时，导演、编舞者甚至选角导演都看不出来。摩根直到玛丽自己说出来才知道真相。玛丽决定排演一场关于“只有一只手臂”经历的舞台剧，剧名叫《爵士手》。明白了吗？《爵士手》——她是专业舞者——《爵士手：独臂女子的故事》。
And I hung the post card up in my room along with a bunch of other letters that people had sent me. And pretty soon, people in my cabin had started asking me. They said, "Oh, who is that?" And I said, "Oh, that's Mary. She's my Pilates teacher. She's great." And they were like, "Oh, does Mary only have one arm?" And I said, "No, Mary has two arms." And they said, "Oh, well in the postcard, she only has one arm."
我把这张明信片挂在房间里，和别人寄给我的信放在一起。很快，营房里的人开始问我。“哦，那是谁？”我说：“哦，那是玛丽。她是我的普拉提老师。她很棒。”他们问：“哦，玛丽是不是只有一只手臂？”我说：“不，玛丽有两条手臂。”他们说：“哦，可是明信片上她只有一只手臂。”
And I looked at them. And I was like, "No, no. Mary definitely has two arms. They must be doing some sort of special effects for the show. You know, Mary is a dancer. She was a cheerleader. I see her do Pilates all the time. I see her twice a week all the time. I go to her classes. I mean, Mary definitely has two arms." And they said, "OK! Why did she write a show about only having one arm?" And I said, "I don't know. She's creative!"
我看着他们说：“不，不。玛丽绝对有两条手臂。一定是剧组用了什么特效。你知道，玛丽是舞者，她曾是啦啦队长。我经常看她做普拉提，每周两次，一直都能看到。我上她的课。我的意思是，玛丽绝对有两条手臂。”他们说：“好吧！那她为什么要写一个关于只有一只手臂的剧？”我说：“我不知道。她很有创意！”
But when Morgan calls her mom on the phone, she mentions what the girls at camp had said. And her mom reassures her, "No, no, no. Don't be silly. Of course Mary has two arms. We both know that." Her mom-- Karen is her name-- told me, sure, she knew that Mary's show had that subtitle, Tales of a One-Armed Woman.
但当摩根打电话给妈妈时，她提到了营地女孩们说的话。她妈妈安抚她说：“不，不，不。别傻了。玛丽当然有两条手臂。我们都知道。”她妈妈——凯伦——告诉我，她确实知道玛丽的剧有那个副标题《独臂女子的故事》。
You know, I didn't really think anything of it. I thought it could have been like a metaphor for something else. Like working at a deficit, something like that.
你知道，我没多想。我以为那可能是什么隐喻。就像在某种缺失下工作之类的。
Yeah, yeah, yeah. She had one arm tied behind her back?
对，对，对。就像她有一只手被绑在背后一样？
Right. And then you start paying attention. And you realize, oh my god!
对。然后你开始注意观察，然后你意识到，天哪！
And then, later that summer, I got home. And my mom said, "Morgan, I have something to tell you." And I was like, "What?" And she was like, "We're such idiots, and Mary does really only have one full arm."
后来那个夏天我回家了。我妈说：“摩根，我有件事要告诉你。”我问：“什么？”她说：“我们真是笨蛋，玛丽确实只有一只完整的手臂。”
So the fact that you went to her for an entire school year twice a week--?
那么，你每周两次去上她的课，整整一个学年——？
I was definitely embarrassed, and I definitely felt really, really stupid. And I know that-- I've spoken to some other women in our class about this. And they, also, they're like, "I felt so stupid." Because it's like, how do you not notice? You're spending so much time with someone. And it's just completely invisible.
我确实感到很尴尬，也觉得自己真的非常非常愚蠢。我知道——我和班上其他一些女性谈过这件事。她们也说：“我感觉自己太蠢了。”因为，你怎么可能没发现呢？你和一个人相处了那么长时间，而这竟然完全隐形。
Yeah. What was the buzz in class? Were there are a lot of people who didn't know?
是的。班上的反响如何？有很多不知道的人吗？
Oh, I think barely any people knew.
哦，我想几乎没人知道。
There's a famous quote that's attributed to an old-time magician named Harry Kellar who died back in 1922. Though as best as I can figure, nobody knows if Harry Kellar really said this. But apparently, he was such a master of misdirection, of getting an audience to look exactly where he wanted them to look and never look anywhere that he did not want them to look, that people claim that he said, quote, "A brass band playing at full blast can march openly across the stage behind me followed by a herd of elephants, yet no one will realize that they went by." Not that he ever tried that. Nobody thinks that.
有一句名言出自一位老牌魔术师哈里·凯拉之口，他死于1922年。据我所知，没人确定哈里·凯拉是否真的说过这句话。但显然，他是错觉大师，能让观众看向他想让他们看的地方，而不看任何他不想让他们看的地方，以至于人们声称他说过：“一支铜管乐队在我身后大声演奏，后面跟着一群大象，大摇大摆地穿过舞台，可没人会意识到他们经过。”并不是说他尝试过，没人会这么想。
Well, today on our radio show, Hiding in Plain Sight, we meet people who do what Harry Kellar never achieved-- they are the elephant on stage and the brass band. And nobody notices. We will meet this woman who demonstrates Pilates in front of people for years without them noticing her fake arm. We will meet the man who brought down the Cali drug cartel from the inside. He was their own director of security. And more from WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
今天在我们的广播节目《隐藏在光天化日之下》中，我们将见到一些做到了哈里·凯拉从未实现过的事的人——他们就是舞台上的大象和铜管乐队，而无人察觉。我们将见到这位在人们面前演示普拉提多年却无人发现她假臂的女性。我们将见到那位从内部摧毁卡利贩毒集团的男人，他曾是他们的安全主管。更多内容来自WBEZ芝加哥，这是由公共广播国际发行的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
Act one, There's Something About Mary. So I guess I've now put this off long enough. It is time to finally Mary Archbold, one-armed woman. She was born that way.
第一幕，关于玛丽的那点事。我想我已经推迟够久了。现在终于要见到玛丽·阿奇博尔德了，那位独臂女子。她天生如此。
I can hide it. It's definitely now a lot of stuff I do subconsciously. It's inherent in the way I move.
我可以隐藏它。这绝对是我现在下意识做的很多事情，它已经融入了我的动作方式。
Do I have this right? You told one of our producers-- or maybe your husband told one of our producers-- that you were in a production of West Side Story , and they didn't know that you had one arm, most of the cast, until the cast party?
我没理解错吧？你告诉我们的制片人——或者可能是你丈夫告诉我们的制片人——你曾出演《西区故事》，剧组大多数人都不知道你有一只手臂，直到庆功宴上？
Yes, yes. We were about probably five weeks into a run of a three-month production. And we had a cast party, and someone pointed it out. And the majority of the people I danced with-- I mean, and these were my dance partners-- did not know.
是的，是的。我们演了三个月，大约到了第五周。我们办了场庆功宴，有人指了出来。我和我共舞的绝大多数人——我的意思是，他们可是我的舞伴——都不知道。
And then is that moment for you a moment of horror or a moment of pride?
那么，那一刻对你来说是恐惧还是骄傲？
Half and half. There's the horror of what reaction is it going to be?
一半一半。有对反应未知的恐惧。
Yeah.
嗯。
And then there is the quiet pride that maybe you saw me as me before you saw me as an actor with a disability.
然后是一种平静的骄傲，也许在你把我视为残疾演员之前，你先把我视为“我”本人。
Do you feel like those two things are contradictory?
你觉得这两件事矛盾吗？
Yes.
是的。
Yeah, I'm not sure I understand that. It's like you're saying you want them to see you.
嗯，我不确定我理解了。就像你是说你想让他们看到你。
Mm-hm.
嗯。
But "you" includes the fact that you have only one full arm.
但“你”本身就包含你只有一只完整手臂的事实。
True, but it's not my leading characteristic. And oftentimes when people find it out first, that's sort of how they describe me. I'm like categorized, one-arm Mary.
没错，但这并不是我的主要特征。很多时候，当人们先发现这点时，他们就以此来描述我。我就被贴上了标签，“独臂玛丽”。
But everyone, when you see them, you see something, some superficial thing in their hair or the way they're dressed, or their age, or whatever it is, or their race, just whatever it is.
但每个人，当你看到他们时，你会看到一些东西，比如头发上的一些琐碎特征，或者穿着方式，或者年龄，或者无论什么，或是种族。
Right.
对。
And they get classified.
他们会被分类。
And I'd be happy to be classified among any other things. You can call me the short girl. You can call me the brunette girl, the blue-eyed girl, whatever you want to say, just not the disabled girl. And it's funny. At home, with my family, with my son, with my husband, I never wear my arm. I'm a lot more functional without it. I can chop. I can do everything much easier without it. So maybe it's a vain thing that I go through all of this.
如果能被归类到其他特征中我会很开心。你可以叫我矮个子女孩、深色头发的女孩、蓝眼睛的女孩，随便你怎么说，就是别叫残疾女孩。这很有趣。在家里，和家人、儿子、丈夫在一起时，我从不戴假肢。没有它我反而更灵活，我切菜，做所有事情都轻松得多。所以也许我经历这一切只是一种虚荣心。
A vanity thing?
虚荣心？
Yeah, absolutely. And because I am a performer, it's sort of a professional necessity because otherwise, the only role I'll be called in for is wounded vet who just came home from Afghanistan. And this way, I get called in for housewife. I get called in for mom.
对，绝对是。而且因为我是表演者，这算是一种职业必要性，否则我能接到的唯一角色就是刚从阿富汗回来的受伤老兵。这样一来，我还能扮演家庭主妇，还能扮演妈妈。
As for her techniques, for how she manages to misdirect people from noticing her hand, they are all startlingly simple. They're so simple that hearing them makes you realize how easily tricked we all are, how unobservant we are in so many situations.
至于她如何通过误导让人们忽略她的手臂，这些技巧简单得惊人。它们太简单了，听完你就会意识到我们是多么容易被欺骗，在许多情况下我们是多么缺乏观察力。
There are the basics. She always wears long sleeves to cover her prosthesis, so only the hand shows. Though the hand is a giveaway. It's worn down so the skin is shiny and doesn't look like skin.
有一些基本技巧。她总是穿长袖来遮盖假肢，所以只露出手。尽管那只手本身就是个破绽，它磨损得皮肤发亮，看起来不像真皮肤。
When she goes out on auditions for choreographers, she does big gestures and expressions. And it's over so quick, they actually never get a chance to notice that her wrist doesn't bend and her fingers don't move. When she needs to demonstrate poses in Pilates class that would expose the hand and arm and give her away, she just uses one of the students as a model.
当她去给编舞者试镜时，她做夸张的手势和表情。动作太快，他们根本没机会注意到她的手腕不能弯曲，手指不能活动。当她在普拉提课上需要演示动作而可能暴露手臂时，她就用学生来当模特。
And in every situation, professional and personal--
在每种情况下，无论是职业还是个人——
I stand on a certain side so that they really only see my real arm. It's all about misdirection. If you're looking very busily at my right side, you won't notice that my left side's not doing much.
我站在特定的一侧，这样他们真的只能看到我的真手臂。这全靠误导。如果你忙着看我的右侧，就不会注意到我的左侧没在做什么。
What about where you put your hand? Would you consciously keep it below people's sight line?
你手放在哪里？你会自觉地把它放在人们视线以下吗？
Oh, yes. Like at a party, I will not hold a drink in my hand. I will take a sip and put it back down, because if I meet somebody, they're going to want to shake my hand.
哦，是的。比如在聚会上，我不会手里拿酒。我会抿一口就放回原处，因为如果我见到某人，他们会想和我握手。
Oh, I see. And if you had a drink in your hand, you would have to put the drink down to shake your hand.
哦，我明白了。如果你手里拿着酒，你就得放下酒杯去握手。
Right, I wouldn't just--
对，我不能就——
And that would be unnatural.
那样很不自然。
Right.
对。
Because normally, what you would do is you'd switch from one hand to the other--
因为正常情况下，你会从一只手换到另一只手——
And then shake hands.
然后再握手。
And then shake. But you can't do that. So you--
然后再握。但你做不到。所以你——
So I always put a drink down on a table.
所以我总是把饮料放在桌上。
What else?
还有什么？
If someone comes at me-- and these are the people, oh, drives me crazy-- where they take both hands. The handholders when they meet people, and they're like, "Oh, it's so nice to meet you!" And they shake your hands, these people scare the hell out of me. So I'll how often cut them off at the pass. If they're going to reach out for my hands, I'll grab a hand and pretend to spin into them and spin out, like we're dancing. Or I say, "I'm a hugger. Give me a hug!"
如果有人朝我过来——这些人最让我抓狂——他们握住双手。那些见面喜欢握住双手的人，说“见到你真高兴！”他们握着你的手，这些人真把我吓坏了。所以我经常先下手为强。如果他们伸手要握我的手，我会抓住一只手，假装转进他们怀里再转出来，就像我们在跳舞。或者我说：“我喜欢拥抱。给我个拥抱吧！”
But isn't a hug kind of a dangerous thing, too? Because if they feel your left arm against them, then--
但拥抱不是更危险吗？因为如果他们感觉到你的左臂靠着他们，那——
It won't touch them.
它不会碰到他们。
It won't touch them?
不会碰到？
Yes, only my right arm will.
是的，只有我的右臂会触碰。
Is it true that before you were with your husband, you would go out on dates with boys. And you wouldn't let them know originally? Like when they first were going out with you, you didn't let them know? That wasn't the first thing you would say?
真的吗？在你和你丈夫在一起之前，你会和男生约会。最初你不让他们知道？就像刚开始约会时，你没让他们知道？那不是你会说的第一件事？
No, absolutely not.
不，绝对不是。
So how far would it get?
那会进展到什么程度？
Depends on the guy. I would get physical with certain guys, and we would get a certain amount. And they still wouldn't know.
取决于那个人。我和某些人会有肢体接触，甚至进展到一定程度，他们依然不会知道。
But you have your shirt still on, right?
但你还穿着衬衫，对吧？
Yes.
是的。
OK.
好的。
But if the shirt came off, funnily, the left sleeve would stay on. So the rest of the shirt could come off, but I would leave the left sleeve on.
但如果衬衫脱了，有趣的是，左袖子会留着。所以衬衫其他部分可以脱掉，但我会留下左袖。
Wait, and they wouldn't notice anything weird?
等等，他们不会注意到什么不对劲吗？
I mean, you were a college guy once. I mean, were you concerned about the left sleeve? If there was a shirt open, are you going to be looking? "Let me check out her elbow joint and see what that looks like."
我的意思是，你曾经也是个大学生。你当时会关注左袖吗？如果衣服敞开着，你会盯着看吗？“让我检查一下她的肘关节看看长什么样。”
But when you're that close to somebody, at some point, your hand touches their left arm, right? Like--
但当你离某人那么近时，某个时刻，你的手会碰到他们的左臂，对吧？比如——
Not if it's under a pillow!
如果它在枕头下面就不会！
Because it's made of silicon-- not if it's under a pillow?
因为它是由硅胶做的——不在枕头下面吗？
Yes, I would wrap my arm underneath a pillow that would be under their head so that they wouldn't realize that my hard arm is underneath them.
是的，我会把手臂裹在一个枕头下面，枕头就在他们头下面，这样他们就不会意识到我坚硬的手臂在他们下面。
And then, with those boys, would there come a point with some of them where you would have to reveal, "Oh, by the way, just one arm?"
然后，对于那些男生，会不会有个时刻你不得不揭露：“哦，顺便说一下，只有一只手臂？”
There was one guy that I actually really did like. And we went out on three dates. And on the fourth date-- and we had smoochy-smooched up until then, nothing too much-- but I felt like I needed to come clean with him. And I did at dinner. And he didn't take it so well.
有一个男生我真的很喜欢。我们约会了三次。第四次约会时——在此之前我们只是亲吻了一下，没什么过激行为——但我感到需要对他坦白。晚餐时我说了。他接受得不太好。
He came back at me with, "Why do you think so little of me that I would care?"
他反驳我：“你怎么会觉得我那么肤浅，会介意这个？”
That's a good question. What did you say?
真是个好问题。你怎么说的？
I said, "I don't think so little of you." At the time, I said, "Maybe I think so little of me that you wouldn't want me with a prosthetic arm."
我说：“我并不觉得你肤浅。”当时我说：“也许是我自己太自卑了，觉得你不会想要一个戴假肢的伴侣。”
Of course, that was long ago. She's performed that whole Jazz Hand show about her experience as a one-armed person and invited her students and all kinds of people she'd been fooling to come and see it. At her wedding, because she had a sleeveless gown, she got opera gloves to conceal her arm. And she actually had them specially made to be long enough to cover her prosthesis. And then, in the end, she realized that everybody at the wedding already knew the truth. They already knew and accepted her, and she didn't wear the gloves.
当然，那是很久以前的事了。她表演了整场《爵士手》来讲述作为独臂人的经历，并邀请了她的学生和各种被她蒙在鼓里的人来看。在婚礼上，因为她穿的是无袖礼服，她买了歌剧手套来遮盖手臂。她甚至让人专门定制了足够长的手套来遮住假肢。最后她意识到，婚礼上的每个人其实都已经知道了真相。他们已经知道了并接纳了她，于是她没有戴那些手套。
Act two, Objects May be Closer Than They Appear. Anton DiSclafani has this story of a person, a human being, who is completely visible, in plain sight, close, nearby, but utterly, confusingly, confoundingly, frustratingly unreachable.
第二幕，物体可能比看起来更近。安东·迪斯卡法尼带来了一个关于一个人的故事，一个活生生的人，完全可见，就在眼前，近在咫尺，却显得如此混乱、令人费解、极其无法触及。
This February, my husband, Matt, found a wallet on the front steps of our apartment. He was walking our dog. The wallet looked custom-made, brown leather with braided edges and a Celtic design embossed on the front along with the initials, JJV. It had $300 inside and a license-- Julian Vinegas, which listed a St. Louis address a street away.
今年二月，我丈夫马特在我们公寓门前的台阶上发现了一个钱包。他当时在遛狗。钱包看起来是定制的，棕色皮革，边缘有编织设计，正面压印着凯尔特图案以及缩写JJV。里面有300美元和一张驾照——朱利安·维内加斯，地址显示在离我们一个街区外的圣路易斯。
"Was it stolen?" I asked my husband.
“是被偷的吗？”我问丈夫。
"Stolen by someone not interested in cash?"
“被一个对现金不感兴趣的人偷的？”
It was a little bit of a mystery how a fully intact wallet came true reside, literally, on our front steps. It went without saying that we would return the wallet and cash to Julian Vinegas. I floated the idea of going to the police, but my husband rejected it. " The Wire ," was all he said. Most of Matt's knowledge of the police comes from watching The Wire , and the cops on The Wire would've definitely stolen the money.
一个完好无损的钱包出现在我们门前台阶上确实有点神秘。不用说，我们一定会把钱包和现金归还给朱利安·维内加斯。我提出报警，但我丈夫拒绝了。“《火线》”，他只说了这一个词。马特大部分的警察知识来自观看《火线》，而《火线》里的警察绝对会偷那笔钱。
I looked for Julian Vinegas on Facebook. He came up on my first search-- Julian Vinegas, St. Louis, Missouri. His security settings wouldn't let me post on his wall, so I sent him a message. This was so easy. But why stop there?
我在Facebook上找朱利安·维内加斯。我在第一次搜索时就找到了——朱利安·维内加斯，密苏里州圣路易斯。他的安全设置不允许我在他的墙上留言，所以我给他发了消息。这太容易了。但为什么要止步于此呢？
My husband and I went to Julian's apartment. I pushed the buzzer, and after a couple of long minutes of waiting, a window raised above us. "Yeah?" a distinctly unfriendly voice called.
我和丈夫去了朱利安的公寓。我按了门铃，等待了几分钟后，窗户在我们上方升起。“谁啊？”一个非常不友好的声音喊道。
"Are you Julian Vinegas?" He was not. Julian Vinegas had apparently moved, and he didn't leave a forwarding address.
“你是朱利安·维内加斯吗？”他不是。朱利安·维内加斯显然搬走了，而且没留下转发地址。
When we got home, I checked Facebook. There was no message from Julian, but there was a post on his wall about a concert he'd been to the night before. "Jane's Addiction was a blast last night. However, I somehow made it home without my phone, keys, and wallet. I never lose things! WTF. Anybody got any leads?"
回家后，我查看了Facebook。没有朱利安的消息，但他的墙上有一篇关于前一天晚上看音乐会的帖子。“简的瘾君子音乐会太棒了。但是，我不小心回家时弄丢了手机、钥匙和钱包。我从不丢东西！我勒个去。有人有什么线索吗？”
"I have a lead!" I shouted at the computer. "Check your messages!" A little while later, another post.
“我有线索！”我对着电脑大喊。“查查你的消息！”过了一会儿，又有帖子。
"I'm starting to feel like maybe I stashed them in the house somewhere, but I've checked everywhere-- including the back of the toilet, the oven, and the freezer."
“我开始觉得我是不是把它们藏在房子里的某个地方了，但我到处都找过了——包括马桶后面、烤箱和冷冻库。”
"Check your messages!"
“查查你的消息！”
Then I remember that Facebook puts all the messages sent you by people who aren't friends into a folder labeled "other," which many people don't know exists. I couldn't friend Julian because of his privacy settings. But I could see his friend list, so I friended several of his friends and messaged them. And I emailed Julian at likely Gmail addresses-- [email protected] , [email protected] . No response.
然后我记得Facebook会把所有非好友发送的消息放入一个标为“其他”的文件夹中，很多人甚至不知道它的存在。因为隐私设置，我无法添加朱利安为好友。但我能看到他的好友列表，所以我加了他的几个好友并给他们发了消息。我还向朱利安可能使用的Gmail地址发送了电子邮件——[email protected], [email protected]。没有回应。
"You're getting obsessed," my husband said. But I was just getting started. There were other leads in Julian's wallet-- three frequent buyer cards from Smoothie King, a coupon card labelled Passport Club that promised 20% off hats at various hat stores, a business card for an attorney, a Sur la Table gift card, a FedEx gift card, a ticket voucher to a local movie theater, a receipt from a record store called Vintage Vinyl, where he bought season six of Weeds , a very faded student ID from the University of Puget Sound.
“你变得走火入魔了，”我丈夫说。但我才刚刚开始。朱利安的钱包里还有其他线索——三张来自冰沙王（Smoothie King）的常客购买卡，一张名为“护照俱乐部”的优惠卡，承诺在各家帽子店享受八折优惠，一张律师的名片，一张Sur la Table礼品卡，一张联邦快递礼品卡，一张当地电影院的票根，一张来自Vintage Vinyl唱片店的收据，他在那里买了第六季的《单身毒妈》，一张非常破旧的普吉湾大学学生证。
I called the University of Puget Sound. The woman who answered was certain she would be able to give me Julian's info. She said the University of Puget Sound kept very good track of its alumni. But there was no Julian Vinegas in their databases.
我给普吉湾大学打了电话。接电话的女士确信她能给我朱利安的信息。她说普吉湾大学对校友的记录非常完善。但他们的数据库里没有朱利安·维内加斯。
I called Vintage Vinyl, but they'd never heard of Julian Vinegas and had no record of him. I called the number on the attorney's business card. But the woman who answered refused to give out any information. I called Smoothie King, where Julian had amassed three punch cards. The woman there said she had not heard of him, but that I could leave the wallet at the store. And if he came back, they'd return it, which seemed like a poor way of doing things for various reasons.
我给Vintage Vinyl打了电话，但他们从没听说过朱利安·维内加斯，也没有他的记录。我拨打了律师名片上的电话，但接电话的女士拒绝提供任何信息。我给冰沙王打了电话，朱利安在那里积攒了三张打孔卡。那里的女士说她没听说过他，但我可以把钱包留在店里。如果他回来，他们会归还，但这出于各种原因看起来不是个好办法。
I still hadn't gotten a reply on Facebook. On Julian's wall, I saw that he went to something called Metal Mondays at a St. Louis bar called Limits. I called the bar and left a message. I thought surely somebody would get back to me-- one of his friends or the bar. They did not.
我依然没收到Facebook的回应。在朱利安的墙上，我看到他去了圣路易斯一家叫Limits的酒吧参加“金属星期一”。我给酒吧打电话并留了言。我想肯定有人会回复我——他的朋友之一或者酒吧。他们没有。
I read his wall a dozen times a day. A week passed, and then another. He seemed to have given up on the wallet, mentioned it less and less. I got to know Julian Vinegas.
我每天读他的墙十几次。一周过去了，又一周。他似乎已经放弃了那个钱包，提及它的次数越来越少。我开始了解朱利安·维内加斯。
I learned that he hung out with friends a lot. He partied a lot. He liked music a lot. He didn't seem to particularly care about punctuation. And though I had so much access to his thoughts, to his whereabouts, I was unable to let him know I existed. I felt like a stalker. I felt like a ghost.
我知道他经常和朋友聚会。他经常参加派对。他非常喜欢音乐。他似乎不太在意标点符号。尽管我有这么多渠道去了解他的想法、他的行踪，但我还是无法让他知道我的存在。我觉得自己像个跟踪狂，我觉得自己像个幽灵。
And then, Julian posted that he was going to a Raekwon concert at the Gargoyle. "This is it!" I thought. "If he's not there, I'll turn over the wallet to the police, crooked cops be damned." Matt, who had become my unwilling accomplice, sat with me at the bottom of the stairs at the Gargoyle. I knew exactly what Julian looked like, because I had looked at dozens of his pictures. But just to be safe, I asked men if they were Julian even when they only vaguely resembled him. One guy told me, "No." And his friend yelled out, "But he could be!"
然后，朱利安发帖说他要去Gargoyle酒吧看Raekwon的演唱会。“就是现在！”我想。“如果他不出现在那儿，我就把钱包交给警察，不管警察是否腐败。”马特成了我不情愿的同谋，和我一起坐在Gargoyle的台阶下。我清楚地知道朱利安长什么样，因为我看过几十张他的照片。但为了保险起见，我甚至问那些长得稍微有点像的人是不是朱利安。一个人告诉我不，但他朋友喊道：“但他可能是！”
We waited. The concert was going to start soon, and I didn't have any proof that Julian was going to be there except a Facebook post from a few days before. And he had been out since 3:31 AM last night, so I thought maybe he was tired?
我们等待着。演唱会马上就要开始了，除了几天前的一条Facebook帖子，我没有任何证据表明朱利安会去。而且他昨晚凌晨3点31分还在外面，所以我以为他可能累了？
Then, he walked down the stairs. I recognized him immediately.
然后，他走下楼梯。我立刻认出了他。
"Are you Julian Vinegas?" I asked. Before he could even confirm that he was Julian Vinegas, I handed him his wallet. "Wow," he said. Immediately, he tried to give me $40, which I didn't take. He seemed happy to see his wallet, but not euphoric. This moment, a complete stranger not only finding his wallet but going to such great lengths to return it, somehow did not seem as improbable to him as to me.
“你是朱利安·维内加斯吗？”我问。在他甚至还没确认自己是朱利安·维内加斯之前，我就把钱包给了他。“哇，”他说。他立刻试图给我40美元，我没收。他看到钱包似乎很高兴，但并不狂喜。这个时刻，一个完全陌生的路人不仅找到了他的钱包，还费尽周折地归还，在他看来似乎并不像对我来说那么不可思议。
We chatted for a few minutes. It was kind of like meeting a celebrity. You think it will just be so incredible that your mind won't be able to handle actually meeting someone who you know so much about. And then it's like, yeah, your mind does handle it.
我们聊了几分钟。感觉就像见明星一样。你以为那将是非常难以置信的，以至于你的大脑无法处理真正见到一个你如此了解的人。然后感觉就像，是的，你的大脑确实能处理。
Julian had moved two blocks away from me to another apartment. He'd lost the same exact wallet twice before. "Really?" I asked.
朱利安搬到了离我两个街区外的另一处公寓。他之前还丢过两次一模一样的钱包。“真的吗？”我问。
"Yes," he said, "and it always gets returned to me like a boomerang." I wanted to say, "No, it is not like a boomerang. It got returned to you because the wallet became my problem, and I focused my obsessive mind on it and went to lengths that most people would not." But I didn't say that.
“是的，”他说，“它总是像回旋镖一样回到我手里。”我本来想说：“不，它不像回旋镖。它之所以回到你手里，是因为这个钱包成了我的难题，我集中了强迫症般的精神，付出了大多数人不会付出的努力。”但我没说出来。
We saw things differently, he and I. And I realized, standing there, that I didn't know Julian Vinegas at all. I thought I did. But I didn't.
我们看待事物的角度不同。站在那儿我意识到，我根本不了解朱利安·维内加斯。我以为我了解，但我不了解。
Anton DiSclafani. Her book, The Yonahlossee Writing Camp for Girls , comes out next summer. Coming up, Coke Brothers. And by that, of course, I mean guys who sell cocaine for a living and how a guy who they knew and trusted sent them to prison. Car-tel Talk in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
安东·迪斯卡法尼。她的书《约纳洛西女子写作营》明年夏天出版。接下来，可卡因兄弟。当然，我的意思是那些以卖可卡因为生的人，以及一个被他们信任的人如何把他们送进监狱。稍后我们将继续从芝加哥公共广播电台和公共广播国际播放《卡特尔对话》。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, Hiding in Plain Sight, stories of people doing just that.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。当然，我们每周都会选择一个主题，为您带来关于该主题的不同故事。今天的节目是《隐藏在光天化日之下》，关于那些正是这样生活的人的故事。
We've arrived at act three of our show. Act three, The Seven Year Snitch. At its height in the early '90s, the Cali drug cartel controlled 80% of all the cocaine in the world. It was a $7 billion a year international business.
我们来到了节目的第三幕。第三幕，七年告密者。在90年代初的全盛时期，卡利贩毒集团控制了全世界80%的可卡因。这是一项每年70亿美元的国际生意。
But the cartel collapsed. Its former leaders went to prison, mostly because of one man, a high-ranking cartel insider who decided that he wanted out, and he went to the authorities. Though I have to say that "going to the authorities" is nothing like a guy in Jersey ratting out a mafia boss here in the United States. This was Columbia, a country with no functioning judicial system. The cartel had bought off Colombian cops, prosecutors, politicians, judges. Karen Lowe tells the story of the man who stood up to all of that while staying and working right under the noses of the Cali godfathers.
但该卡特尔崩溃了。其前领导人入狱，主要归功于一个人，一位卡利卡特尔的高层内部人士，他决定退出并找到了当局。虽然我必须说，“找到当局”可不像新泽西的一个人在美国告发黑手党老板那样。这里是哥伦比亚，一个司法体系不健全的国家。卡特尔买通了哥伦比亚警察、检察官、政治家和法官。凯伦·洛讲述了这个站在这些人对立面，同时就在卡利教父眼皮底下工作和生活的男人的故事。
The man who took down the Cali cartel was named Jorge Salcedo. He's in witness protection in the US now. In order to talk to him, my producer and I met him at a hotel near the beach in Southern California. Jorge was a little nervous around the mic.
摧毁卡利卡特尔的男人名叫豪尔赫·萨尔塞多。他现在在美国接受证人保护。为了采访他，我的制片人和我在南加州海滩附近的一家酒店见了他。豪尔赫对着麦克风有点紧张。
Is it going to be that close all the time?
它会一直那么近吗？
It will be that close, yeah, yeah. Yeah,
它会一直那么近，是的。
You're going to be tired.
你会累的。
I will get tired. That's true.
我会累的。那是真的。
Jorge Salcedo is a greying, soft-spoken engineer who loves literature and tinkering with things. And that's who he was before all this started. He was doing well in Colombia. He ran an assembly line that made car batteries. He was designing a way to recycle motor oil.
豪尔赫·萨尔塞多是一位头发花白、说话轻声细语的工程师，热爱文学，喜欢修补东西。这就是在这一切发生之前他的样子。他在哥伦比亚过得很好。他经营一条生产汽车电池的流水线。他还在设计一种回收机油的方法。
And he was bored. Jorge's father had been a high ranking member of the military. And now, in his 40s, Jorge wanted that kind of prestige and adventure. So he joined the Colombian Army Reserves, became a surveillance and intelligence specialist. And then, one day in 1989, Jorge was working at his battery factory in Bogota when he got a visit from an old friend.
而且他感到很无聊。豪尔赫的父亲曾是军队的高层军官。现在，40多岁的豪尔赫渴望那种威望和冒险。所以他加入了哥伦比亚预备役部队，成为了一名监视和情报专家。1989年的某天，豪尔赫在波哥大的电池厂工作时，接到了一位老友的拜访。
The guy's name was Mario del Basto. Mario had recently quit the military, and he had a request for Jorge. Here's how Jorge recalls it.
那家伙叫马里奥·德尔·巴斯托。马里奥最近刚从军队退伍，他有一个请求给豪尔赫。以下是豪尔赫的回忆。
He just came to my office. And he was very secretive about what was going to happen. He told me, "You need to come with me to Cali." I said, "Where are we going?" "I'll tell you later. Just come, don't ask me." I trusted him so much that I said, "I don't see anything bad."
他直接来到我的办公室。对于即将发生的事情，他非常神秘。他告诉我：“你必须跟我去卡利。”我说：“我们要去哪儿？”“我稍后再告诉你。跟我走就行，别问。”我非常信任他，所以说：“我不觉得有什么坏处。”
And he said, "We're going to go to The Intercontinental Hotel, and they're going to be calling us. And just wait for what they're going to tell us, because frankly, I don't know what it is."
他说：“我们要去洲际酒店，他们会打电话给我们。等着听他们告诉我们什么，因为坦白讲，我也不知道是什么。”
The people who were going to be calling were members of the Cali cartel. Since leaving the military, Mario had gone to work for the cartel, and Jorge knew that. But he got on the plane with Mario anyhow. I asked Jorge why. Jorge said he suspected that he might be meeting with some mid-level Cali guys, and that seemed OK with him.
打电话的人是卡利卡特尔的成员。离开军队后，马里奥为卡特尔工作，豪尔赫知道这一点。但无论如何，他还是和马里奥上了飞机。我问豪尔赫为什么。豪尔赫说他怀疑自己可能只是去见几个卡利的中层人员，这对他来说似乎还可以。
It intrigued him. He thought it might even be a business opportunity. I kept asking Jorge to clarify. Do you think it was OK to do business with the drug cartel?
这引起了他的兴趣。他甚至认为这可能是一个商业机会。我不断要求豪尔赫澄清。你觉得和贩毒集团做生意没问题吗？
You're asking me? I see that your questions go to, "How can he accept something like this?" to, "How corrupt is he already?" But when you are a Colombian, you get used to something that is not conceivable other ways.
你是在问我吗？我看你的问题走向是：“他怎么能接受这样的事？”再到“他到底有多腐败？”但当你是一个哥伦比亚人时，你会习惯一些无法想象的事情。
Our country has never been in peace. I have been all the time living under violent circumstances.
我们的国家从未享受过和平。我一直生活在暴力环境下。
When he got to Cali, Jorge was surprised to find that his meeting was not with some mid-level guys, but with the cartel's four godfathers. And what they wanted from him was equally surprising. They wanted help in their war with the Medellin cartel. You've probably heard of Pablo Escobar, the ruthless leader of the Medellin cartel. They wanted Jorge to help them kill him.
当到达卡利时，豪尔赫惊讶地发现他见面的不是什么中层人员，而是卡特尔的四位教父。而他们想要他做什么更是同样令人惊讶。他们想要他在与麦德林卡特尔的战争中提供帮助。你可能听说过巴勃罗·埃斯科巴，麦德林卡特尔的残暴领导人。他们想要豪尔赫帮他们杀掉他。
I was introduced by Mario who just said, "Gentlemen, here is Jorge Salcedo, the person whom I told you about." And the first sentences ever pronounced, "Well, we have been told about your connections with a group of mercenaries in England."
马里奥介绍我说：“先生们，这就是豪尔赫·萨尔塞多，我跟你们提到过的那位。”第一句话就是：“好吧，我们听说过你和英国的一群雇佣兵有联系。”
This is why they reached out to Jorge. While he was in the Army Reserves, Jorge had come in contact with a group of British mercenaries, a crew of about a dozen men who ran secretive, off-the-books missions. Jorge was their primary contact in Colombia, and the cartel knew that.
这就是他们找豪尔赫的原因。在预备役部队期间，豪尔赫接触过一群英国雇佣兵，这是一群大约十几人的团队，执行秘密的、非官方的任务。豪尔赫是他们在哥伦比亚的主要联系人，卡特尔知道这一点。
They wanted to hire these British mercenaries to kill Escobar. They told Jorge--
他们想雇佣这些英国雇佣兵杀掉埃斯科巴。他们告诉豪尔赫——
"As you know, we've been attacked by Pablo Escobar. And we're very worried for our families." And then, they were very explicit with their plans. They got very much in detail. They said, "We're going to get him in this place." It was already a plan that they had developed. So when I was told, "This is what we're going to do," at that moment, I knew they had made me aware of a big secret. And I had no way out.
“如你所知，我们一直受到巴勃罗·埃斯科巴的攻击。我们非常担心家人的安全。”然后，他们非常明确地说明了计划。他们非常详细。“我们要在那个地方抓住他。”这是一个他们已经制定的计划。所以当我被告知“这就是我们要做的”时，那一刻，我知道他们让我知道了一个大秘密。我已无路可退。
No way out. I know, this is the way it always happens in the movies, right? But it's true. The cartel had just laid out a plan to kill Escobar in a very detailed way. And now Jorge knew.
无路可退。我知道，这和电影里的一模一样，对吧？但这确实发生了。卡特尔刚才非常详细地提出了杀死埃斯科巴的计划。现在豪尔赫知道了。
Jorge says at that moment the conversation in his head went something like this. "I'll help take down Escobar, but I won't be involved in any drug trafficking or anything dirty. Once Escobar's gone, I'll take my money, leave, maybe start my own security business."
豪尔赫说那一刻他脑子里的对话是这样的。“我会帮助摧毁埃斯科巴，但我不会参与任何毒品走私或肮脏的勾当。一旦埃斯科巴不在了，我会拿钱走人，也许自己开个安全公司。”
I asked him over and over again about this. And he kept saying, "You pretty much have to be a Colombian to understand." Escobar was out of control, murdering people on a scale that was shocking, even for a drug lord. One notorious incident, he blew up an airliner with 107 people on it because he wanted to kill one man, a presidential candidate who, it turned out, wasn't even on the plane.
我一遍又一遍地问他这个问题。他一直说：“你得是哥伦比亚人才能理解。”埃斯科巴完全失控了，谋杀的规模令人震惊，即便对毒枭来说也是如此。一个臭名昭著的事件是，他炸毁了一架载有107人的客机，只为了杀一个人，一个后来发现根本不在飞机上的总统候选人。
Escobar was terrorizing the country. So Jorge did want Escobar dead. Nearly everyone did.
埃斯科巴在恐吓全国。所以豪尔赫确实想让埃斯科巴死。几乎每个人都想。
Over the next four years, with the help of the British mercenaries, the cartel tried twice to kill Pablo Escobar. But they didn't succeed. Eventually, Escobar was killed in a shootout with Colombian authorities in 1993.
在接下来的四年里，在英国雇佣兵的帮助下，卡特尔两次尝试杀掉巴勃罗·埃斯科巴，但都没有成功。最终，埃斯科巴在1993年与哥伦比亚当局的交火中被杀。
Meanwhile, Jorge had risen to chief of security for the Cali cartel. Now his job was to protect the head godfather, Miguel Rodriguez Orejuela, his four wives, and all their children.
与此同时，豪尔赫已经升为卡利卡特尔的安全总管。现在他的工作是保护首席教父米格尔·罗德里格斯·奥雷胡拉、他的四个妻子以及他们所有的孩子。
My presence was required every time that he was going to move. He would tell me in advance what sort of movements were expected.
他每次出行都需要我的陪同。他会提前告诉我预期的行程。
Jorge was actually into the work. It gave him a way to indulge his military and technical skills. But he was originally hired to help kill Escobar. So the day after the authorities shot him, Jorge asked to speak with Miguel, the head of the cartel.
豪尔赫实际上挺投入这份工作的。这给了他一种展示军事和技术技能的方式。但他最初是被雇来杀埃斯科巴的。所以在当局击毙他的第二天，豪尔赫要求和米格尔——卡特尔的首领说话。
And basically, the conversation was, "My mission is over. I'm happy to see that nothing happened to your family, to yourself. But it is the time for me to retake the original life that I had years ago."
基本上，谈话内容是：“我的使命结束了。很高兴看到你和你的家人安然无恙。但现在是我重回多年前生活的时候了。”
And he said, "No, no, no, Jorge. You're very valuable to us. Don't even think about it. Much better times are coming." They had some sort of gratitude for what I had done, but on the other hand, it may be that gratitude was that if he leaves, he knows too much and I have to do something else. I didn't look at that under that perspective.
他说：“不，不，不，豪尔赫。你对我们太有价值了。想都别想。更好的日子还在后面。”他们对我做的事情心存感激，但另一方面，这种感激可能意味着，如果他走了，他知道得太多，我必须采取行动。我当时并没有从那个角度看问题。
Really? In all that time, it didn't occur to you that you had too much knowledge to leave?
真的吗？在那么长的时间里，你没想过你掌握了太多的知识，无法离开吗？
I was, in a way, a little too naive.
在某种程度上，我有点太天真了。
However he justified his role-- for instance, Jorge says he never saw drugs, he didn't touch a gram of the stuff-- there was no way he could escape the violence. He heard about grisly murders and cartel assassins.
无论他如何为自己的角色辩解——比如，豪尔赫说他从未见过毒品，没碰过一克——他都无法逃避暴力。他听说了恐怖的谋杀案和卡特尔杀手的事。
Once, he was at a hacienda as four suspected snitches in other rooms were strangled and then disemboweled.
有一次，他在庄园里，另外几个房间里有四名疑似告密者被勒死并随后被开膛破肚。
And I just said, "Next is me, maybe in this very night." So that was a time where also I said, "Oh my god, I don't belong here. This is not my world. What am I doing here?"
我对自己说：“下一个可能就是我，也许就在今晚。”那是另一个时刻，我说：“天哪，我不属于这里。这不是我的世界。我在这里做什么？”
Jorge was stuck in a cartel that was growing quickly. With Escobar gone and his organization in disarray, the Cali cartel soaked up Medellin's drug business. A US Justice Department official told Congress that, at its peak, the cartel was, quote, "The most prolific and successful criminal enterprise in history."
豪尔赫被困在一个飞速扩张的卡特尔中。随着埃斯科巴的倒台和其组织陷入混乱，卡利卡特尔吞并了麦德林的毒品业务。一位美国司法部官员告诉国会，在巅峰时期，该卡特尔是，引用，“历史上最成功、最猖獗的犯罪企业。”
But there was one way the cartel was still vulnerable. If you could get cartel members extradited to the United States, then they could be prosecuted for bringing drugs into the country. And while Colombia was notoriously soft on the cartels, the US had no problem handing down tough sentences.
但卡特尔依然有一个软肋。如果你能让卡特尔成员被引渡到美国，他们就能因走私毒品被起诉。虽然哥伦比亚对卡特尔极其纵容，但美国处理严厉判决绝不手软。
But in the early 1990s, the cartels found a way around that, too. Colombia outlawed extradition, made it unconstitutional. Cali cartel attorneys had actually helped craft the law's language. But the extradition ban didn't cover everyone in the cartel. There was a kind of loophole.
但在90年代初，卡特尔也找到了规避手段。哥伦比亚宣布引渡违法，使其违宪。卡利卡特尔的律师们实际上帮忙草拟了该法律的措辞。但引渡禁令并不涵盖所有人。存在某种漏洞。
William Rempel is a reporter who spent more than 10 years reporting Jorge's story for a book he wrote called At the Devil's Table .
威廉·兰佩尔是一位记者，他花了超过10年时间为他的一本书《恶魔的餐桌》报道豪尔赫的故事。
There's a technicality, and the law also included the fact that this protection extended only to Colombians-- Colombian citizens. So anybody in the Cali cartel-- and they employed Guatemalans, Cubans, Chileans, Argentinians-- all of those members of the cartel were still subject to extradition. And some of those people had risen to high places.
有一个技术细节，法律规定该保护仅适用于哥伦比亚公民。所以卡利卡特尔里的任何人——他们雇用了危地马拉人、古巴人、智利人、阿根廷人——所有这些成员仍然可以被引渡。其中一些人已经身居高位。
First among these people in high places was the cartel's accountant, Guillermo Pallomari. Pallomari was Chilean, which meant he could be extradited. He also had intimate knowledge and computerized records of all the cartel's transactions, including bribes to officials. If the authorities nabbed Pallomari, they'd have a blueprint of nearly every act of corruption the cartel was involved in.
这些人中身居高位的第一人是卡特尔的会计，吉列尔莫·帕洛马里。帕洛马里是智利人，这意味着他可以被引渡。他还有卡特尔所有交易的内部知识和电脑记录，包括贿赂官员。如果当局抓住了帕洛马里，他们就有了卡特尔所涉及的几乎每一项腐败行为的蓝图。
He presented such a risk to the cartel that they asked him to go into hiding. The Cali godfather, Miguel Rodriguez Orejuela, wasn't one to accept risks like this. Miguel was a no-nonsense kind of guy dubbed The Lemon because of his sour disposition. And even though Miguel liked Pallomari, Miguel knew something had to be done. So he talked to Jorge.
他给卡特尔带来了巨大的风险，以至于他们要求他躲藏起来。卡利教父，米格尔·罗德里格斯·奥雷胡拉，可不是那种能接受这种风险的人。米格尔是个务实的人，因为脾气暴躁被称为“柠檬”。即使米格尔喜欢帕洛马里，他也知道必须做点什么。所以他找了豪尔赫。
Miguel tells me, very sadly, "You know, Pallomari has served us very much. But we have agreed that he needs to die. So there is a killer with the name of Yusti. And it's your task to coordinate with this killer that he kills him." At that particular moment, I was praying. I was saying, "Oh my God, you work it out so I will not do this. Just help me. I'm not going to do it."
米格尔非常悲伤地告诉我：“你知道，帕洛马里为我们服务了很多。但我们一致认为他必须死。所以有个叫尤斯蒂的杀手。你的任务是协调杀手去杀掉他。”那一刻，我在祈祷。我说：“哦，上帝，请运作让这件事不会由我来做。请帮帮我。我不会做的。”
On the other side, I was just being a candidate for an Oscar Award by my performance. I said, "No problem. I'll take care of the thing."
另一方面，我在表演上成了奥斯卡候选人。我说：“没问题，我会处理的。”
Jorge actually kind of hated Guillermo Pallomari. The accountant had been behind some business decisions for the cartel that he disagreed with, and he thought Pallomari had a tendency to be sloppy. But still, Jorge says he never ordered anyone to be killed.
豪尔赫实际上有点讨厌吉列尔莫·帕洛马里。这位会计曾是卡特尔一些商业决策的幕后推手，豪尔赫对此并不赞同，而且他认为帕洛马里往往做事马虎。但即便如此，豪尔赫说他从没下令杀过任何人。
Going after Escobar was one thing. He was a national menace. But this was different. So he says he made up his mind. He wasn't going to kill Pallomari.
去对付埃斯科巴是一回事。他是一个国家祸害。但这完全不同。所以他说他下定决心了。他不会去杀帕洛马里。
That left him two options. He could leave or, reporter William Rempel says, he could take down the entire Cali drug cartel. He choose option number two.
这只剩下两个选择。要么离开，或者，记者威廉·兰佩尔说，摧毁整个卡利贩毒集团。他选择了方案二。
And the only way to bring down the cartel would be to actually save the life of the accountant who could deliver such a terrible blow to the inner secrets of the cartel, and to help the United States and the Colombian government capture Miguel, the boss of the bosses.
摧毁卡特尔的唯一方法就是救下那个能对卡特尔内部机密造成致命一击的会计的性命，并帮助美国和哥伦比亚政府逮捕老板中的老板——米格尔。
How was Jorge going to do this? He couldn't trust anyone in Colombia. There was no way to know who might be working for the cartel. And so Jorge did the only thing he could think of, the same thing you or I or the average seventh grader might think of if we needed help taking down an international crime syndicate. Jorge went to a phone booth he knew wasn't tapped and called the CIA.
豪尔赫要怎么做？在哥伦比亚他谁也信不过。无法知道谁可能是为卡特尔工作的。所以豪尔赫做了他能想到的唯一一件事，如果你我或者一个普通的七年级学生需要摧毁一个国际犯罪集团时，可能会想到的那一件事。豪尔赫走进了一个他知道没有被窃听的公用电话亭，给中情局打了电话。
He didn't know anyone at the CIA, of course, so he called the main number for CIA Headquarters in Langley, Virginia. He got the front desk.
当然，他不认识中情局的任何人，所以他打了弗吉尼亚州兰利中情局总部的总机号码。电话转到了前台。
Let me tell you what I said. I said, "I am calling from Cali, Columbia. And I just have very valuable information about the head of the Cali cartel, and I--"
让我告诉你我说了什么。我说：“我从哥伦比亚卡利打来。我刚掌握关于卡利卡特尔首领的非常有价值的信息，而且我——”
The operator asked him for the name of the person he wanted to talk to. He explained he didn't have that. "How about an extension?" she said. Well, no. He didn't have that either. Again, William Rempel.
接线员问他想找谁通话。他解释说没有。她说：“那分机号呢？”好吧，没有。也没那个。再次提到威廉·兰佩尔。
It ended with her saying, "Well, maybe you should call back when you know who you want to talk to."
最后她说：“嗯，也许你应该在知道想找谁之后再打来。”
I walk across the square. And then again, I was myself praying, help me, God. I'm totally alone. There's nothing I can do.
我穿过广场。我再次祈祷，上帝帮帮我。我彻底孤立无援。我无能为力。
Then, Jorge stumbled on one another long-shot solution. He knew a lawyer in Florida who had done some work for the cartel, and Jorge happened to read in the newspaper that US authorities were after the lawyer.
然后，豪尔赫撞上了一个长线解决方案。他认识佛罗里达的一位律师，曾为卡特尔工作过，豪尔赫碰巧在报纸上读到美国当局正在追捕那位律师。
So Jorge contacted the attorney with a pretty simple proposition. Put me in touch with American authorities, and I'll talk. And they'll be so grateful to you, it'll get you leniency.
所以豪尔赫联系了那位律师，提出了一个简单的提议。帮我联系美国当局，我就谈。他们会非常感激你，这对你也会从宽处理。
This worked. The lawyer knew someone in US Customs in Miami. That person knew someone in the Drug Enforcement Administration. Soon, Jorge was on the phone with two DEA agents, David Mitchell and Chris Feistl, who were already on the ground in Colombia. They agreed to meet in a cane field 45 minutes outside of Cali. But Chris says Jorge had a few demands. Jorge was scared of any Colombians, because they might be collaborating with the cartel.
这成功了。律师认识美国迈阿密海关的人。那个人认识禁毒署的人。很快，豪尔赫就和两名DEA特工戴维·米切尔和克里斯·费斯特通了电话，他们当时已经在哥伦比亚实地工作。他们同意在卡利郊外45分钟的一个甘蔗林里见面。但克里斯说豪尔赫有几个要求。豪尔赫害怕任何哥伦比亚人，因为他们可能是卡特尔的同伙。
Well, before we got there, Jorge said on the phone that he had two conditions to us meeting. One was he said you have to come alone. And I said, "There's no way I'm coming alone. I'm coming with my partner. We don't go anywhere by ourselves in Cali." And he said, "OK, that was fine." But then, he also said, "I don't want to see anybody who's Colombian. If you bring a Colombian with you or someone who even appears to be Colombian, the deal's off."
嗯，在那之前，豪尔赫在电话里说，他有见面有两个条件。第一个是他要求我们必须独自前来。我说：“不可能独自前来。我会和我的搭档一起来。在卡利我们从不独自去任何地方。”他说：“OK，那样可以。”但随后他还说：“我不想见到任何哥伦比亚人。如果你带了哥伦比亚人来，或者看起来像哥伦比亚人的人，交易取消。”
And I told him, "Jorge, don't worry. When you see us, you won't be disappointed."
我告诉他：“豪尔赫，别担心。当你见到我们时，你不会失望的。”
Both agents were blond, both over 6' tall.
两位特工都是金发，身高都超过6英尺。
And when Jorge arrived and he started walking up to us, and my partner, Dave, said, "Hey, Jorge, are we American enough looking for you?" And that kind of broke the ice, because it was obviously a tension-filled moment for him as well as for us. And Jorge smiled, and he laughed a little bit. And we got down to business.
当豪尔赫到达并开始朝我们走来时，我的搭档戴夫说：“嘿，豪尔赫，我们长得够美国人吗？”这打破了僵局，因为对他和我们来说，这显然是一个充满紧张的时刻。豪尔赫笑了，笑得有点开心。我们开始谈正事了。
First, they went after Miguel. Other cartel members had recently been nabbed, and Miguel was getting paranoid-- so paranoid that he didn't let his own security chief, Jorge, know which apartment he was staying in. Jorge knew the building, but nothing more.
首先，他们对付的是米格尔。其他卡特尔成员最近刚被捕，米格尔变得非常多疑——多疑到连他的安全主管豪尔赫都不知道他住在哪个公寓。豪尔赫知道楼栋，但仅此而已。
But Jorge told the agents that Miguel liked to work very late. They did some nighttime surveillance and noticed that the lights stayed on in only two apartments-- one on the fourth floor and one on the eighth floor.
但豪尔赫告诉特工，米格尔喜欢熬夜工作。他们进行了一些夜间监视，注意到只有两个公寓灯火通明——四楼和八楼。
So one night, Jorge calls Miguel's driver. The lights flick on. It's the fourth floor. They had him.
所以一天晚上，豪尔赫给米格尔的司机打了电话。四楼的灯亮了。他们抓到他了。
Three days later on the morning of July 15, 1995, the two DEA agents rolled into the neighborhood with dozens of hidden Colombian National Police-- hidden, Chris says, the only way they could think of.
三天后，1995年7月15日上午，两位DEA特工带着几十名潜伏的哥伦比亚国家警察开进了社区——克里斯说，潜伏的方式是他们唯一能想到的。
We wanted to get something that would kind of fit in at that hour of the morning. And the best thing that we could come up with would be chicken trucks. It was a pretty messy situation, and some of the troops were not very happy. I don't think it was a very comfortable ride for them.
我们想要一些在那个清晨的时间点看起来不太突兀的东西。我们能想到的最好办法就是运鸡的卡车。情况非常混乱，有些士兵不太高兴。我不觉得那是个舒服的行程。
Jorge didn't go on the raid. He kept his distance to maintain his cover and waited for his phone to ring. The first call he got was from one of his security guys in the cartel.
豪尔赫没有参加突袭。他为了保持掩护保持距离，等着电话响。他接到的第一个电话来自卡特尔的一名保安。
I got an early call from somebody saying they had penetrated the area and they're going to be searching the apartment.
我接到一个早期的电话，说他们渗透进区域了，正要搜查公寓。
So although he initiated the raid on the apartment, Jorge was still the cartel security chief. And he had a job to do. He told his men to get out of there, it was too late. They couldn't save Miguel.
所以尽管他发起了对公寓的突袭，豪尔赫依然是卡特尔的安全总管。他还有工作要做。他告诉手下赶紧离开，已经太晚了。他们救不了米格尔。
And my instruction was everybody leave the area. I don't want anybody arrested for any reason. I was warning my people, but I was more than warning. I was covering up myself. I was just playing the charade.
我的指令是所有人离开区域。我不想任何人以任何理由被捕。我在警告我的人，但我不仅是在警告。我是在为自己打掩护。我只是在演戏。
And then, a problem. The DEA had kept the target of the raid a secret from Colombian authorities till the last minute. And now, a Colombian prosecutor met them at the building and told the DEA they didn't have the right paperwork to raid Miguel's apartment. For 90 minutes, the DEA waited, frustrated.
然后，出了个问题。DEA对突袭目标一直对哥伦比亚当局保密，直到最后一分钟。现在，一名哥伦比亚检察官在大楼拦住他们，告诉DEA他们没有搜查米格尔公寓的合法文书。DEA沮丧地等待了90分钟。
Once the paperwork was finally fixed and the DEA made it into the apartment, three people were there-- two housekeepers and Miguel's driver. Jorge had told the DEA, if you see the driver, Miguel is there. The driver was always with Miguel.
一旦文书修正，DEA进入公寓，那里有三个人——两名管家和米格尔的司机。豪尔赫曾告诉DEA，如果你看到司机，米格尔就在那儿。司机总是和米格尔在一起。
I turned to my partner, Dave, and I said, "We're in the right place. He's here. Now, we just need to find him."
我转过身对搭档戴夫说：“地方对了。他就在这儿。现在，只需要找到他。”
They searched all the rooms and grilled Miguel's driver. Nothing. Meanwhile, across town, Jorge was hanging out with the cartel members at a bakery, trying to look like the security boss while also picking up clues to feed the agents. He walked over to Miguel's son to demonstrate his concern.
他们搜查了所有房间并审问了司机的米格尔。一无所获。与此同时，在城市另一头，豪尔赫正和卡特尔成员在一家面包店闲逛，努力装成安全主管，同时搜集线索提供给特工。他走到米格尔儿子旁边演示关心。
I just came to ask, "Is there anything you know?" He said, "No, nothing. He's inside there, but hopefully he will go into his vault." And I said, "Does he have a vault?" "Oh, yeah, he does." "OK, so let's pray for the best and wait. There's nothing we can do about that." And at that time, a beeper started sounding coming from the agents.
我只是来问问：“你知道什么吗？”他说：“没有，什么都没有。他在里面，但希望他会进入金库。”我说：“他有金库？”“哦，有的。”“OK，那我们祈祷一切顺利，静候佳音。我们对此无能为力。”就在这时，特工的传呼机响了。
He goes to a pay phone and contacts the agents. Again here's Chris.
他走到公用电话亭联系特工。克里斯再次描述。
And then, after hours of Jorge sitting there and hearing different bits of information, we were able to learn that there was a secret compartment in the apartment, and that it may have been in one of the bathrooms. And once concealed inside that secret compartment, it would be very difficult for us to find.
几个小时的观察和听到零星消息后，我们了解到公寓里有一个秘密隔间，它可能在其中一个浴室里。一旦隐藏在那，我们很难找到。
So they checked the bathrooms. Again, nothing. Hours passed. The Colombians involved in the raid got so bored that they started watching soccer on one of Miguel's big screen TVs. But Jorge managed to give the agents one additional clue. Jorge told them to compare Miguel's apartment with the others in the building, see if any differences stood out. Chris noticed one of the bathrooms wasn't like the others. It was smaller. And one of the cabinet doors seemed off. It hit the toilet when you tried to open it.
所以他们搜查了浴室。还是一无所获。几个小时过去了。参与突袭的哥伦比亚人无聊到开始在米格尔的一台大屏幕电视上看足球赛。但豪尔赫成功给特工提供了一条额外线索。豪尔赫让他们比较米格尔的公寓和其他单位，看看是否有不同之处。克里斯注意到其中一个浴室和别的不一样。它更小。一个橱柜门看起来有点不对劲。当你试图打开它时，它会撞到马桶。
And I got down on the floor. And first of all, I noticed that the floor was wet, that someone had urinated on the floor. And I thought, "Well, either they were just being sloppy or that was a sign that they didn't want anybody to really get down on the ground and start looking around." So I got down on the floor.
我趴在地板上。首先我注意到地板是湿的，有人在地板上撒尿了。我想：“嗯，要么是他们太邋遢，要么是个信号，他们不希望任何人趴在地上找东西。”所以我趴在地板上。
And as I was looking under one of the cabinets, I was able to see a very thin tube, like a plastic tube, coming out of the wall under the cabinet and up under the sink. And I thought, that's really strange. If he's anywhere, it has to be behind that wall.
当我观察其中一个橱柜下时，我看到一条非常细的管子，像塑料管一样，从橱柜下的墙壁延伸出来，一直到水槽下面。我想，这真是太奇怪了。如果他在哪儿，肯定就在那面墙后面。
The agents brought in sledge hammers and drills and started boring into the cement walls. By now, though, the cartel had called in some chits. A regional Attorney General showed up and ordered the agents out of the building. They tried to argue, but it was over. Chris called Jorge and told him the news.
特工拿来大锤和电钻，开始钻进水泥墙。然而此时，卡特尔已经动用了一些关系。一名区域检察长出现并命令特工离开大楼。他们试图争辩，但结束了。克里斯打电话告诉豪尔赫这个消息。
I felt devastated. I learned what my fate was going to be.
我感到万念俱灰。我知道我的下场会是什么样了。
Jorge had put everything on the line for this raid, and they'd failed. And now the cartel was trying to figure out who snitched. Who led the authorities to Miguel's apartment?
豪尔赫为这次突袭押上了一切，但他们失败了。现在卡特尔正在调查谁告密。谁带当局去了米格尔的公寓？
I said, "Well, so far, nobody has pinpointed me. And nothing was going to link me." I quickly saw the thing. I've never been at the apartment. There's no way I can be blamed for knowing about the vault, so I'm clear.
我说：“嗯，目前还没人锁定我。没有任何东西能关联到我。”我很快看到了情况。我从没去过那个公寓。没人能因为知道金库而责怪我，所以我洗清了嫌疑。
Not exactly. Jorge knew that if he was going to avoid suspicion, he had to amp up his performance as security chief. So his next move was to urgently find out who fed information about Miguel to authorities-- to essentially investigate himself.
并非如此。豪尔赫知道如果想避免嫌疑，就必须加强作为安全主管的表演。所以他的下一步是紧急找出是谁向当局提供了关于米格尔的信息——本质上是调查他自己。
Jorge's plan was to cast doubt on others. First up, Miguel's driver, Castillo. Castillo had been in the apartment during the DEA raid, so maybe he'd be able to pinpoint the leaker. Miguel's son told Jorge to meet Castillo someplace 45 minutes outside of Cali. Along for the ride were two other cartel members. They left at 5:00 AM with Jorge at the wheel. One sat next to him. The other sat behind him.
豪尔赫的计划是让其他人怀疑。首先是米格尔的司机卡斯蒂略。卡斯蒂略在DEA突袭时在公寓，所以也许他能锁定告密者。米格尔的儿子让豪尔赫去卡利郊外45分钟的地方见卡斯蒂略。随行的还有其他两名卡特尔成员。早上5点他们就出发了，豪尔赫开车。一个人坐在他旁边。另一个人坐在他后面。
Were you afraid that you were being set up to be killed?
你害怕被做局杀掉吗？
Absolutely. I was just concerned that I have somebody behind me who could just put a rope on my neck, and you're over.
绝对。我只是担心后面有个人能用绳子勒住我的脖子，你就完了。
When they met with the driver, the only information he offered was that the agents kept calling their informant Patricia. That was true.
当他们见到司机时，他唯一提供的信息是特工一直称呼他们的线人叫“帕特里夏”。这是真的。
Any time the agents got on the phone with their informant-- who, of course, was Jorge-- they called him Patricia. When Jorge heard the driver, Castillo, bring up his raid code name, he jumped at the opportunity it provided.
任何时候特工给线人——当然就是豪尔赫——打电话时，都叫他帕特里夏。当豪尔赫听到司机卡斯蒂略提起他的突袭代号时，他抓住了这个机会。
And I just moved the conversation to, "That's very good news because we can now establish our whole investigation towards women that had been in the apartment. It's going to be about 5% of visitors. So how many women have been there?" So I started exploiting the situation, trying to derail the investigation in a way that was favorable to me.
我把谈话引向：“那是个好消息，因为我们可以建立针对公寓女性的调查。大概是访问者的5%。那么有多少女性去过那里？”所以我开始利用这种情况，试图以对我有利的方式扰乱调查。
Rerunning that scene in his head as they rode back, Jorge worried that he appeared a bit too enthusiastic about the tidbit Castillo gave. Of course they would know Patricia was a code name. The DEA wouldn't be stupid enough to use an informant's real name. Jorge had to find out what the cartel guys knew.
回程路上在脑海里重演那个场景时，豪尔赫担心自己对卡斯蒂略提供的点滴信息表现得太热情了。当然他们会知道帕特里夏是个代号。DEA不会蠢到用线人的真实名字。豪尔赫必须找出卡特尔成员知道些什么。
So I quickly got to Cali. And then, I said, "I need to stop here in a bank." The person who runs the bank is a lady friend of mine. I need to talk to her just a minute." So I step out of the car about five minutes. And the minute I started on, they started talking again.
所以我很快到了卡利。我说：“我得在银行停一下。运行银行的是我的一位女性朋友。我得跟她谈几分钟。”所以我在车外呆了大约五分钟。我一走，他们就开始谈话了。
How did Jorge know they started talking again? Because he'd been recording them the whole time. He'd stashed a little tape recorder in a compartment of the driver's side door.
豪尔赫怎么知道他们又开始谈话了？因为他全程录音了。他在司机侧车门的隔间里藏了一个小录音机。
Too easy. I just had to pull my left hand down. I knew where the record button is. Click it, leave it. And I was careful, very careful, to touch the record and not the play button. You can imagine.
太简单了。我只需要把左手伸下去。我知道录音按钮在哪儿。按下去，离开。我非常小心，非常小心地只触碰录音而不是播放按钮。你可以想象。
[MEN SPEAKING IN SPANISH]
[西班牙语交谈声]
In the tape, there was a point where they make a comment, [SPEAKING SPANISH]. "Do you notice how he became after I mentioned Patricia?" And he said, "Well, he's acting funny. Definitely, he's kind of nervous." That was the conversation between these two guys.
录音中有一处他们评论说，[西班牙语交谈声]。“注意到我提到帕特里夏后他变得怎么样了吗？”他说，“嗯，他表现得很奇怪。毫无疑问，他有点紧张。”那是那两个人的对话。
[MEN SPEAKING IN SPANISH]
[西班牙语交谈声]
While they were talking, Jorge was in the bank pretending to visit a woman. The guys in the car suddenly hear this buzz.
当他们交谈时，豪尔赫正在银行假装拜访一位女士。车里的家伙突然听到嗡嗡声。
[VIBRATION AUDIBLE]
[嗡嗡声]
It was Jorge's DEA beeper.
那是豪尔赫DEA传呼机的声音。
I had the beeper that I had been using with Chris and David on vibration mode in the trunk of the car. So they were talking. And there it goes, brrp, brrp, this beep. And I think they were listening to music some. But they were having a conversation about, it has to be me.
我把一直和克里斯与戴维使用的传呼机调成振动模式放在后备箱里。所以他们谈话时，它就开始了，嗡嗡，嗡嗡。我想他们当时可能听着音乐。但他们正在讨论告密者肯定是我。
[BEEPER BUZZES]
[传呼机响声]
And then, there was a third one that [INAUDIBLE] it, brrp, brrp. And all of  a sudden, they say, "Oh my god, what's that? It's a microphone!"
然后响了第三下，[听不清楚]，嗡嗡，嗡嗡。突然他们说：“天哪，那是什么？是麦克风！”
[BEEPING SOUND]
[哔哔声]
It's a stupid thing because microphones don't sound. They produce no sound. But these guys were-- and I was precisely coming out of there. So what this guy does is turns the switch, the air conditioning starts shhh uhhh to cover up, to make noise to cover up. And he said, "He's coming. He's coming."
这是件蠢事，因为麦克风不会响。它们不产生任何声音。但这些人——而我正从那里出来。所以这人做的是打开开关，空调开始轰隆作响来掩盖声音。他说：“他来了。他来了。”
When Jorge listened to the whole tape later, his chest caved. Now he knew for sure he was under suspicion. He and his family were in grave danger. Plus, there was still a hit out on Pallomari the accountant. And Miguel was still at large in a new safehouse. Jorge couldn't risk any more. It was time to call in the agents, Chris and Dave.
当豪尔赫后来听完录音时，心凉了半截。现在他确定自己被怀疑了。他和家人处于严重危险之中。此外，卡特尔依然对会计帕洛马里有追杀令。米格尔依然躲在新的避难所里。豪尔赫不能再冒任何险了。是时候呼叫特工克里斯和戴夫了。
Again, they met in the cane field outside of Cali. Just like the raid on Miguel's house and the two attempts to kill Pablo Escobar, the meeting quickly turned into a fiasco. Instead of the empty field they expected, the place was swarmed with taxis and police cars. Turns out a taxi driver had been murdered in the field the night before. Chris says it wasn't long before a police officer asked what they were doing there.
他们再次在卡利郊外的甘蔗林见面。就像对米格尔家的突袭和两次杀害巴勃罗·埃斯科巴的尝试一样，会面迅速变成了一场闹剧。现场没出现预想中的空旷田野，反而到处是出租车和警车。结果是前一天晚上一个出租车司机在田里被杀了。克里斯说不久后就有警察问他们在干什么。
And the routine questioning led to asking for ID. And we assured him that we weren't doing anything. So my partner, Dave Mitchell, had a lot of Colombian pesos. And we basically went to the police officials and said, "Here, take this money. Leave us alone. We're not doing anything wrong." and his response was, "If you're not doing anything wrong, why are you giving me some money?"
例行盘问导致要出示证件。我们向他保证我们什么也没做。我的搭档戴维·米切尔带了很多哥伦比亚比索。我们基本向警察官员说：“拿着钱。别管我们。我们没做任何坏事。”他的回应是：“如果没做坏事，为什么要给钱？”
It was a good question, because I didn't have an answer for it at that point. And finally, Jorge just said--
真是个好问题，因为我当时没法回答。最终，豪尔赫说——
Well, this is embarrassing to say. But this is the thing. These gentlemen here, they're foreigners. And we're gay. We're just doing some gay stuff.
说出来真丢人。但就是这样。这几位先生是外国人。我们是同性恋。我们只是在做些同性恋的事情。
And we all had a laugh at that. And the police officials had a laugh at it, too. And they left us alone. So we were able to continue our conversation and continue with our strategizing and plotting of the next raid.
我们都笑了。警察官员也笑了。他们没再管我们。所以我们得以继续交谈，继续战略规划下一次突袭。
This time, they knew where to go thanks to a slip-up by a low level cartel worker. A messenger for Miguel's wife had openly talked in front of Jorge about where Miguel's new hideout was. They nailed everything down ahead of time, did all the paperwork and hand-picked a prosecutor.
这一次，多亏了一个低级卡特尔员工的失言，他们知道该去哪里了。米格尔妻子的一个送信人在豪尔赫面前公开谈论了米格尔的新藏身处。他们提前确定了一切，办好了所有文书，并精挑细选了一名检察官。
They were working with the Colombian Navy, which Jorge was pretty sure wasn't compromised. The apartment building was near a mountain, so instead of driving up to the front door, 35 guys descended down extremely difficult terrain to the building. But only five made it into the building in time for the raid. The rest got tangled on the mountainside.
他们与哥伦比亚海军合作，豪尔赫确定海军没有被渗透。公寓楼靠近山边，所以没有开车从前门进入，35个人从极其困难的地形下降到大楼。但只有5个人及时进入大楼参加突袭。其余人在半山腰被困住了。
They broke open Miguel's door with a sledgehammer and raced through the apartment. Here's Chris.
他们用大锤破开米格尔的门，冲过公寓。克里斯描述。
And with the commotion as we continued to make our way through the apartment, I heard one of the Colombian Navy officials say, "I got him, I got him!" And I was like, "OK, well, that's good news." And I was able to run in the back down the hallway and into the master bedroom and into the closet area. And I saw the Colombian Navy official holding Miguel by the shoulder on his shirt. And he grabbed him right as he was trying to access the secret compartment. So had we been another five minutes or so, we probably wouldn't have apprehended him.
伴随着我们继续在公寓里推进的骚动，我听到一名哥伦比亚海军官员说：“我抓到他了，我抓到他了！”我想，“OK，这是好消息。”我能够跑回后面的走廊，进入主卧和衣帽间区域。我看到哥伦比亚海军官员抓住米格尔的衬衫肩膀。他就在他试图进入秘密隔间时抓住了他。所以如果我们再晚个五分钟左右，可能就抓不到他了。
The Colombian officials were jubilant and took turns taking trophy pictures of themselves with Miguel. But Jorge wasn't so happy. He wouldn't be safe until the DEA got him and Pallomari out of the country.
哥伦比亚官员兴高采烈，轮流和米格尔合影作为战利品。但豪尔赫高兴不起来。在DEA把他和帕洛马里带出国外之前，他是不安全的。
Next, the DEA struck a deal with Pallomari. He would testify against the cartel in exchange for safe passage to the United States-- which had an unfortunate side effect. It meant Jorge would have to wait to get out. The DEA was tied up transferring Pallomari and his family.
接着，DEA与帕洛马里达成了协议。他将出庭指控卡特尔以换取安全前往美国——这有一个不幸的副作用。这意味着豪尔赫必须等待才能离开。DEA忙于转移帕洛马里和他的家人。
Having to wait for days, Jorge was terrified. And he knew it was time to confess the truth to his wife, to let her know their lives were about to change completely and permanently. She knew he worked for the Cali cartel, but had no idea he was working with the DEA to bring them down.
等待的日子里，豪尔赫惊恐万分。他知道是时候对妻子坦白真相了，让她知道他们的生活即将彻底且永久地改变。她知道他在为卡利卡特尔工作，但完全不知道他在为DEA工作以摧毁卡特尔。
It was like three days before leaving that I said, "I need to talk to you." And I told her, "We need to talk. And I don't want it to happen here in our house." So I took her out to a field close to the house. All I remember is we were sitting on the grass. And very flatly, I just said, "I need you to know this. I am the person behind the capture of Miguel Rodriguez. And what we need to do is get out of everything we have here. We need to abandon what we have. We need to leave the city, the country." It was such a big shock to her.
就在离开前三天左右，我说：“我得跟你谈谈。”我告诉她：“我们得谈谈。我不想在家里发生。”所以我带她到离家不远的一个田野。我只记得我们坐在草地上。我非常平淡地说：“我需要你知道这一点。我是导致米格尔·罗德里格斯被捕的幕后之人。我们要做的就是放弃我们这里拥有的一切。我们需要放弃我们拥有的。我们需要离开这座城市，这个国家。”这对她来说是巨大的打击。
How did she react?
她什么反应？
SIlent for about 30 seconds, staring at me. And there were tears from both of us. We just grabbed our hands strongly. And she said, "OK, I understand what you have done. So let's face it. It's a fact. When are we leaving?" I said, "I don't know."
沉默了大约30秒，盯着我。我们两个都流泪了。我们紧紧抓住对方的手。她说：“OK，我理解你所做的一切。那就面对吧。这是事实。我们要什么时候离开？”我说：“我不知道。”
10 days after he went into hiding and 7 and 1/2 years since he joined the cartel, Jorge Salcedo boarded a plane in Bogota bound for Miami.
在他躲藏10天后，加入卡特尔7年半之后，豪尔赫·萨尔塞多登上了一架从波哥大飞往迈阿密的飞机。
It was already checked, ready to go. The engines were started already inside the hanger. They opened the doors and we were cleared to take off. When we took off, I just said, "Thank God I'm out." That's it.
它已经检查完毕，准备出发了。引擎已经在机库里启动。他们打开机门，我们获准起飞。起飞时，我只说了：“感谢上帝，我出来了。”就是这样。
I'd put him right up there with one of the best assets that we've ever had.
我会把他列为我们拥有过的最佳资产之一。
Again, DEA agent Chris Feistl.
再次提到DEA特工克里斯·费斯特。
I've told him before, I don't know how you did what you did, because I don't know if I would have the courage or the guts to do what you did, to take that chance and to put it all on the line to try to do the right thing. So I had great admiration for him for that.
我以前对他讲过，我不知道你是怎么做到的，因为我不知道自己是否有那种勇气或胆量去做你做过的事，承担风险并全力以赴去尝试做正确的事。我对他表示由衷的敬佩。
In 1997, Columbia lifted its ban on extradition. Jorge and Guillermo Pallomari, both safe in the States, provided testimony that led to the conviction of many of Colombia's top drug bosses and their enforcers. Scores of police and legislators were fired or sent to prison. The Cali godfathers, Miguel and Gilberto Rodriguez Orejuela, are currently serving 30-year prison sentences in Miami for international drug trafficking.
1997年，哥伦比亚解除了引渡禁令。豪尔赫和吉列尔莫·帕洛马里都在美国获得了安全，他们提供的证词导致了哥伦比亚许多顶级毒枭及其打手的定罪。大批警察和议员被解雇或送进监狱。卡利教父米格尔和吉尔伯托·罗德里格斯·奥雷胡拉目前正在迈阿密因国际毒品走私服30年刑期。
Jorge lives in witness protection in the US. He says his conscience is clear and he's at peace with what he did. Wherever he lives, none of his neighbors or coworkers know anything about his past, but Jorge knows.
豪尔赫在美国接受证人保护。他说他问心无愧，对自己的所作所为感到平静。无论住在哪里，邻居或同事都对他的过去一无所知，但豪尔赫自己知道。
During our interview, a helicopter flew overhead and he had to stop. Jorge told me he's flown lots of helicopters.
采访期间，直升机飞过头顶，他不得不停下来。豪尔赫告诉我他开过很多直升机。
I love flying helicopters.
我喜欢开直升机。
Another time when a chopper flew by, Jorge was even able to identify the manufacturer. It was a Bell, American made. The guy knows his stuff. He knows what he did. He just can't talk about it anymore-- the most important thing about his life, the biggest thing he ever accomplished, and no one has a clue.
另一次直升机飞过时，豪尔赫甚至能识别出制造商。那是贝尔，美国制造。这家伙是个行家。他知道自己的所为。他只是不能再谈论它了——他生命中最重要的事情，他完成过的最伟大的成就，而没人知道。
Karen Lowe in California. Thanks to William Rempel, whose book about Jorge Salcedo, At the Devil's Table , was so helpful to us in putting together this story. Though both William Rempel and Karen Lowe have interviewed Salcedo, neither has any idea where he lives, what city or state.
凯伦·洛在加利福尼亚。感谢威廉·兰佩尔，他关于豪尔赫·萨尔塞多的书《恶魔的餐桌》对我们整理这个故事非常有帮助。尽管威廉·兰佩尔和凯伦·洛都采访过萨尔塞多，但没人知道他住在哪里，哪个城市或州。
Our program was produced today by Brian Reed with Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Sarah Koenig, Jonathan Menjivar, Lisa Pollak, Robyn Semien, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Seth Lind is our operations director. Emily Condon's our office manager. Music help from Damien Graef and Rob Geddes. Production help from Tarek Fouda and Matt Kielty. This is our last show with Matt. He is off to work with our colleagues at Radio Lab . We wish him the very, very best. We hope maybe he'll teach those slackers how to mix or something.
我们的节目今天由布莱恩·里德制作，亚历克斯·布隆伯格、本·卡尔霍恩、莎拉·柯尼格、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔、丽莎·波拉克、罗宾·塞门和南希·厄普代克参与。我们的高级制片人是朱莉·斯奈德。赛斯·林德是我们的运营总监。艾米丽·康登是我们的办公室经理。音乐协助来自达米安·格拉夫和罗布·盖德斯。制作协助来自塔雷克·福达和马特·基尔蒂。这是我们和马特的最后一场节目。他要去和我们在Radio Lab的同事一起工作。我们祝他一切顺利。我们希望也许他能教教那些懒鬼怎么混音之类的。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. WBEZ management oversight for our program by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, my nephew was visiting on college break this week. He came by the office, dropped by. We saw Torey. Torey took the kid's jacket, ripped off one of the sleeves, turned to me, and said,
《美国生活》由公共广播国际发行。我们的节目由老板托雷·马拉蒂亚先生负责管理。你知道，我侄子这周利用大学假期来看我。他来到办公室，顺路进来。我们见到了托雷。托雷拿走孩子的夹克，扯掉一只袖子，转过头对我说，
I mean, you were a college guy once. I mean, were you concerned about the left sleeve?
我指的是，你曾经也是个大学生。我指的是，你当时会关注左袖吗？
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周回来带来更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，公共广播国际。